we are known as the businessman and the
boy uh that is one of the ways that we
are referred to at times by children I
don't know how that happened I think one
child watched a video of ours and called
yeah that's the business the boy really
yeah I've never heard they were like
yeah yeah put put on the businessman and
the
boy the and why didn't you run with that
that's a great like a we
have yeah I have I talk about it all the
time I mean it's one of the first things
I mentioned a long time he's been trying
to make the boy happen for me but you
don't like being the boy I'm not really
up for the boy how do you how do you
identify
uh okay uh he identifies as the
businessman I'm no I'm a guy I'm just
I'm me like business it feels like he's
taking advantage of you if it's like the
businessman and the boy it feels a
little like sketchy and weird it does
listen why are we going to this dark
place hold on but if you heard well
that's the answer to your question if
somebody was like I'm going to see the
businessman and the boy tonight in like
an entertainment context who do you
think would would like be generating the
most laughs the boy right the
businessman is just pulling the strings
but who's he kind of pushing out he's
pushing out the boy so I feel like you
should embrace being the boy because I
think people
like more gray you get in your into your
uh the more gray that seems to be I'm
not knocking because you guys I'll tell
you something we've been doing this
podcast for almost two years and I'm
tell I could say without a doubt the
best hair we've had I'm a big judge of
hair oh well Jack Jackie didn't I mean
she didn't take that bait no I think so
I'm thinking back to all the guests
we've had look this you want to you want
to really consider this yeah before I
give my answer I'm really thinking about
better hair the businessman or the boy
oh gosh here we go oh I don't know you
know what you don't have to the boy I
think I'm sorry fine the boy's got a
bright future ahead of him that's the
point see again the businessman wants
the boy to have the better hair because
the businessman very tasted mimoa kind
of thing oh thank you yeah which is a
compliment yeah you look like you're
using ainet just nothing else I was once
called aquan and the boy I was once
approached by a drunk man in Key West
who came up to me and
said Jason
Mimosa really really so I am now known
as Jason mamosa like the Jason mimosa
and the boy yeah that's that's an even
playing field
hey
he